continuez il vous en prie
il vous écoute avec un plaisir non
dissimulé
alors Laurent plus vous aurez du succès
au cinéma plus vous serez beau
et plus vous serez beau plus vous aurez
de femme et pour vous y habituer je vous
faire une interview à l'un de l'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes prêts il est prêt votre
conception du luxe c'est boire du coca
dans un verre en cristal ou boire du
Pétrus dans un gobelet en plastique
il pense que c'est boire du Pétrus dans
un verre en cristal
pour faire du social vous augmenteriez
les salaires ou vous diminueriez le
temps de travail
il est très peu concerné par la question
il dira que il va augmenter les salaires
mais il est assez démagogues c'est une
période électorale il a besoin de se
faire aimer il a besoin de se faire
aimer par la majorité donc il va dire il
augmente les salaires il diminue tous
les impôts et il offre une maison mobile
pas ou maison témoin Domexpo à qui veut
qui vote pour lui
pour taper la frime vous préférez rouler
sans bornes en Ferrari avec un boudin ou
10 bornes en tracteur avec un top canon
étant donné qu'il vient de la Sarthe il
va répondre qui va préférer être avec un
super beau tracteur qui déglingue je
ramasse et faire du sol qui est aussi
beau qu'une Ferrari et plus cher avec un
canon énorme comme ça
pour vous le plus chaud que ça vous
super cher un tracteur
il vous en prie
il vous écoute avec un plaisir non
dissimulé pour vous le plus choquant
c'est l'interdiction des mariages homo
où la banalisation des divorces hétéro
il a il a envie de répondre autre chose
il a envie de répondre que il comprend
toujours pas que comment ça se fait
qu'avec la télé soit toujours pas marié
encore donc il va répondre un truc
complètement à côté quoi c'est que il
est très jaloux des deux dans quoi qu'il
arrive parce que lui ça il est toujours
pas concerné par ce genre de dilemme ça
l'ennuie beaucoup pour l'un de l'autre
quand même c'est quelque chose qui va
arriver pour garder celle que vous aimez
vous préféreriez l'enfermer dans un
palais ou la sortir avec échangiste
il préférerait les deux il ferait tout
il sortirait la sur multipliée et si
vraiment il y a pas le choix il
enfermerait dans un palais parce qu'il a
pas trop confiance en Lui oh que c'est
beau et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez
un pouce bleu